In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, amen.
The reading from the Sinhaxadeon from A21st, on which we commemorate, the holy, glorious
God-crowned and great sovereigns, Constantine and Helen, equals to the Apostles.
On the 21st of the month, we celebrate the memory of the Holy Emperor crowned by God
and equal to the Apostles Constantine the Great and his mother, Empress Helena.
This account of St. Constantine gives us the opportunity to remind ourselves that the
Sinhaxadeon is on another level the nat of political history.
The veneration of St. Constantine the Great, as with the Constantine elements that have been
preserved in orthodoxy, looks to the edification of the church and the confirmation of its
eschatological dimension.
The glory of the empire is nothing other than a symbol and anticipation of the glory of
the kingdom of God.
It is in this way and not as imperial nostalgia that the faithful venerate the Holy Emperor's
and pray today in this time of secularized democracies for the confirmation of the empire.
St. Constantine the Great, the first Christian emperor, who became by the grace of God a
possible of the Lord among the kings, was the son of the outstanding general Constantius
Chlorus and St. Helena.
He was born in Nisa in 280 and grew up on the battlefield, learning from his father not
only the art of war, but also the wise government of his subjects and clemency towards the Christians.
Shortly after Diocletian's proclamation as emperor in 286, he, having too great an empire
to govern, threatened on all sides by the barbarians and troubled by incessant plotting,
confided the government of the west to his friend Maximian, and a few years later in 293 appointed
two Caesars as auxiliaries to the two Augusti, Galerius Maximianos in the east and Constantius
Chlorus in the west, with jurisdiction over great Britain, Gal and Spain.
To assure himself of the trustworthiness of the latter, Diocletian made him divorce St.
Helena and Mary Maximian's daughter, and moreover, kept the young Constantine as a hostage
in Nicomedia, his capital.
Constantine therefore passed his adolescence in a pagan society at Diocletian's court
and then at that of Galerius, where he was distinguished by his majestic appearance and
valor in combat, but above all by his moral rectitude and goodness, which drew the sympathy
of all who were in contact with him.
He shone with the truly royal virtues of Chastity and forbearance, which lifted him up above
the intrigue and meanness that were usual in the court's circles.
But these qualities also provoked jealousy, especially from emperor Galerius, who constantly
sent him on dangerous campaigns from which Constantine always emerged victorious, acquiring
the greater glory for him.
After the abdication of both Diocletian and Maximian, the two Caesars, Galerius and Constantius
Chlorus were elevated to the rank of Augustus.
Informed of the plots against his son, Constantius, sick and aging, asked that Constantine
visit him, escaping by a hair's breath from the men who had been sent to prevent him,
Constantine hurried to Great Britain, where he had the joy of seeing his father again.
Constantius confided to him the succession of the Western Empire and asked him to help and
protect the Christians who had been violently persecuted ever since Diocletians' edicts.
Shortly after this, Constantius died in York, and Constantine was at once proclaimed
emperor by the army on the 25th of July in 306.
But in the meantime, Galerius, who considered himself to be the first emperor, had designated
two Caesars, Maximinos II, Daya for the East and Severus for the West, with Rome as the
capital.
On the death of Constantius Chlorus, he elevated Severus to the dignity of Augustus, but the
latter was overthrown in a revolt by the people supported by the Praetorian Guard and replaced
by Magzentius, Maximian's son, who very soon inaugurated in Rome a reign of bloody tyranny
and extreme debauchery.
Constantius concluded an agreement with Constantine in which he left him power over the most
westerly regions, with Arles as his capital.
Constantine, respecting the conditions, governed the part that had fallen to him with justice
and goodness.
He was loved by the people and feared by the Germans and the barbarian tribes.
But this situation only lasted a short time, as Magzentius was quickly in friction with
his father, with whom he had shared power.
Maximian took refuge in Constantine's kingdom, but he also attempted to seize power with
the complicity of his daughter, Fausta.
Constantine's second wife, a crafty woman, and an intriguer, who was later the cause of
a great deal of unhappiness to the devout emperor.
The plot was uncovered, and Maximian put an end to his life in 310.
Galerius, being informed of the events that were troubling the Western Empire, and
avid to assume full power, appointed Licinius as Caesar of the West and marched on Rome
with a mighty army.
Overcome by Magzentius, he beat a retreat and turned against Constantine.
But the latter inflicted a comprehensive defeat on him and Galerius perished miserably,
after having promulgated an edict, moderating the general persecution that was raging in
the East in 311.
Maximian's daya, a fanatical pagan and persecutor of Christians, then took the title of Emperor
of the East, and Magzentius remaining alone in Rome undertook a campaign against Constantine
with the aim of claiming the whole of the Western Empire for himself.
Appeal to for help by the Romans, who were suffering under Magzentius' tyranny, Constantine gathered
his troops together, crossed the Alps in September of 312, and easily conquering the towns
of North Italy, reached the outskirts of Rome, where Magzentius had concentrated far greater
forces.
Climbing a hill, Constantine was considering in perplexity the superiority of his adversaries,
when, at midday, an enormous cross made of stars appeared in the sky, around which these
words were written in Greek.
In this sign, thou shalt conquerer.
On the following night Christ himself appeared to the Emperor, and commanded him to make
a cross similar to the one that he had seen in his vision, and to place it as a standard
at the head of his army.
The sign of victory once more blazed forth in the sky, and Constantine believed with all
his heart that Jesus Christ is the one true God, the creator of heaven and earth, who
gives victory to kings, and guides all things to the end that he had foreseen before the beginning
of the world.
When day dawned, he had this labyrinth made, and ordered that it be carried at the head
of his troops, in place of the imperial eagles, as a sign of victory over death and a trophy
of immortality.
This consisted of a long golden spear ending in a cross, topped by a golden crown and
precious stones, at the center of which stood the Lord's symbol, composed of the first two
letters of the name of Christ.
On the transverse of the cross was hung a purple cloth, covered in precious stones, which
sparkled like the sun's rays.
At the decisive battle of Milvius Bridge on the 28th of October in 312, it was the cross
that brought victory.
Maxentius, taking flight to the bridge, got into the boats that he had built, but they capsized
on the crossing, and the tyrant was drowned with all his officers, like Pharaoh and his
horsemen, a four-time in the Red Sea.
Giving thanks to God for this victory that inaugurated a new era of human history, Constantine made
a triumphal entry into Rome, which greeted him as its liberator, Savior and benefactor.
He immediately had the sign of the cross placed high on the principal buildings in the city,
and a statue of the emperor was erected, with him holding the cross in his hand as a sign
of victory and an emblem of the authority he had received from Christ.
From that time, Constantine began to receive instruction in the Christian faith, and applied
himself assiduously to the reading of the Holy Books.
Some Sinaxadia, and the office of this day, mistakenly affirmed that Constantine was baptized
by St. Sylvester when he entered Rome.
In fact, the emperor remained a catacumin for the rest of his life, as was often the case,
and was only baptized just before his death.
He restored all the goods confiscated by Maxentias, recalled the exiles, set the captives free,
and had a search made for the relics of the martyrs who perished in the great persecution.
At the time of this victory over Maxentias, the Christian religion, so long-shamed and persecuted,
was from then on able to emerge from the shadows and rejoice in the sovereign's protection.
Although remaining distinct from political power, the church was, from that time, able
to inspire governors and profoundly transform the lives of men and states with the in-breathing
of evangelical principles.
Some months later, St. Constantine met Licinius in Milan in 313, and the two emperors, who
from then on shared the world, signed an edict, bringing the persecution to an end, and allowing
the Christians to practice their religion freely throughout the empire.
Constantine was proclaimed supreme Augustus, and his sister Constantia was married to Licinius.
Illumined by the grace of God, the Holy Emperor did not only grant general freedom, but also
encouraged the development of Christian worship.
He granted subsidies for the building of churches, and the worthy adornment of the martyr's
homes, and returned the goods of confessors and martyrs that had been confiscated by
the state, having them bestowed on the church if the martyrs had left no errors.
He gave honors to the bishops, whom he received at his table, and was present at local councils
to ensure that peace and concord rained.
While the light of truth shone thus in the west, the darkness of idolatry and tyranny continued
to be maintained in the east by Maximinos Deia, who declared war on Licinius.
Maximinos was, however, defeated in Thrace on the 30th of April in 313.
And Licinius, becoming master of the Eastern Empire, intensified the persecution, imposed
restrictions on the bishops, closed churches, exiled the Christians he could find and confiscated
their goods, and also cruelly punished all who gave help to those in prison.
He forced the dignitaries to offer sacrifice and had injustice and violence hold sway in
all areas of administration.
Learning of these tyrannical measures being taken in the east against the Christians, St.
Constantine raised a mighty army guided by the sign of the victorious cross, and during
a campaign against the barbarians in Pannonia, he entered Licinius' territory in 322.
After a first defeat at Andrianopolis, the tyrant turned back at Byzantium and was then
decisively defeated at the Battle of Christopolis on the 18th of September in 324.
Constantine triumphant in the name of Christ and of truth strove from then on to offer the
unified Roman Empire as a gift to the king of kings.
And like a new apostle had the faith in the One God and his son incarnate for our salvation
proclaimed to the furthest confines of east and west, from Mesopotamia to Great Britain.
Exercising for barons towards prisoners from the enemy army, he immediately had the same
measures towards the church applied in the east as he had earlier decreed in the west.
In an edict proclaimed throughout the empire, he declared that God alone must be seen as
the source of his victories, and that he had been chosen by providence to place himself
at the service of goodness and truth.
He put new magistrates in the provinces whom he forbade to offer pagan sacrifice, and sent
to all the countries under his authority letters condemning idolatry and exhorting to conversion.
He urged all his subjects to follow his example, though without constraining any.
The empire ruled over by a single emperor, thus became an image of the kingdom of God, already
present on earth, in which all men who were reconciled with God could delight in peace
and raise to him constant hymns of thanksgiving.
To this new Christian empire that was to last a thousand years, it was necessary to give
a capital, better placed geographically than Rome and free of the memories of idolatry
and tyranny.
Inspired by a sign from heaven, the devout emperor fixed his choice on the small town of Byzantium
that occupied a pivotal position between east and west.
Inspired by an angel, he himself marked the limits of the new city, and ordered Alfreda,
the master of the works, not to spare any expense in endowing it with monuments and public avenues
that would exceed in glory all the other cities of the world.
At the foundation of the city on the 8th of November in 324, Byzantium received the names
Constantinople and New Rome, and was then dedicated to the Mother of God.
In the middle of the palace an immense cross was erected, adorned with precious stones, and
in the forum there was raised on top of a porphyry column a statue of Constantine in which
holy relics were placed, and at the column's foot the baskets that were used in the miracle
of the loaves and fishes.
The work was done at great speed, and on the occasion of the 25th anniversary of the emperor's
accession on the 11th of August in the year 330, the inauguration of the new capital was
celebrated with great pomp.
Immediately after the victory over Lycinius, Saint Constantine's first care was to establish
and confirm the unity of the church that was gravely threatened by the heresy of Areas,
which had spread from Egypt to various countries as a result of a decree by Lycinius, forbidding
the convoking of local councils.
After having, through the intermediary of Hosea of Cordova, Saint letters of exhortation
to Alexander, Archbishop of Alexandria, and to Areas in which he expressed his anguish
at the divisions, the emperor summoned all the bishops in the world to Nysia for the
first great and holy ecumenical council in 325.
This first assembly of bishops from the furthest parts of the world was a perfect expression
of the fullness of the church and the unity of the Christian Empire.
The emperor sat in the midst of the bishops, resplendent in a garment set with precious stones.
He opened the session with thanksgiving to God for the assembly and exhorted the participants
to peace and to resolve the divisions sewn by the devil in the house of God.
He took part in the discussions and by his gentleness and moderation succeeded in reconciling
the opposing groups.
They then went on to the condemnation of Areas and his adherents and resolved that Easter
be celebrated everywhere on the same date as a sign of the unity of the faith.
To conclude the sessions of the council, Saint Constantine invited all the fathers on the
occasion of the 20th anniversary of his accession to the throne, to a banquet, which presented
a sumptuous prefiguring of the kingdom of God.
He then sent them back to their dioceses in peace, furnished with rich gifts.
In the following year, the Empress Helena, who had just been baptized, undertook a pilgrimage
to Palestine.
It appears that Saint Helena undertook this pilgrimage in expiation for the double murder
that had recently overshadowed her son's reign.
Christmas, the son of Constantine's first wife, had been accused of hatching a plot against
his father.
Shortly after having had him put to death, the emperor realized that this was a false accusation
raised by Faustah, his second wife, who wanted in this way to assure the succession of
her three sons, and he had her executed.
These tragic events are the main reason why historians have cast out on Constantine's personal
sanctity.
But we must place these actions in the conditions of the time, in which the monarch held all
judicial authority in his hands and had the power of life and death over his subjects.
These historians omit moreover to point out the signs of repentance in the emperor that
are implied by the rest of his conduct and his method of government inspired by the principles
of the gospel.
The Empress Helena, who had just been baptized, undertook a pilgrimage to Palestine, during
which the site of Calvary was discovered, and thanks to a miraculous revelation, the
Savior's cross buried in the earth.
Saint Constantine then ordered that a magnificent Basilica dedicated to the resurrection be built
there, and it was inaugurated in 335 on the 30th anniversary of his accession.
Saint Helena also visited other holy places and had churches built in Bethlehem and on
the mount of olives.
She freed captives and gave alms widely throughout the east.
This celebrated an admirable Empress performed another action worthy of being remembered.
She assembled all the women who had vowed perpetual virginity and, placing them on couches, herself
fulfilled the duties of a handmaid, serving them with food, handing them cups and pouring wine,
then bringing a basin and pitcher and pouring out water for them to wash their hands.
After performing these and other praiseworthy actions, the Empress returned to her son,
and, not long after, joyfully entered into the other, better life.
After having given her son much pious counsel and her fervent parting blessing, after her
death, that honor was given to her memory which her steadfast and zealous service of God
merited.
Her funeral took place in Constantinople and her body was later translated to Rome.
The security of the frontiers, having been assured by an adroit interplay of alliances
and the barbarians having turned their swords into plowshares, the devout sovereign could
spend the rest of his reign in peace and could occupy himself with the strengthening of the
foundations and institutions of the new Christian Empire.
He encouraged the spread of Christianity in every way and made profound changes to Roman
law, working to submit them to the evangelical spirit of charity and forbearance.
From the time of his elevation to power, he had decreed that Sunday be a day of rest
throughout the Empire, abolished the sentence of death by crucifixion, forbade gladiatorial
contests, and severely punished rape and sexual assault.
He later emphasized the institution of the family as the basis of social structure and limited
divorce condemned adultery and legislated on the rights of inheritance.
He also lifted the formally promulgated laws against those who remained childless in order
to encourage monasticism, which was, at the time, experiencing a great upsurge and made
large gifts to consecrated virgins, whom he respected to the point of adoration.
When the seat of administration was definitively transferred to Constantinople in 330, the emperor
forbade the celebrating of pagan feasts there and blocked the appointment of pagans to
state functions.
Seeing himself as the bishop of external affairs, he was seen in his governing as a living
image of God, who generously lavishes his gifts on all.
He gave abundant alms to those in need, whether Christians or not, supporting the widows and
being a father to the orphans.
He protected the poor against the demands of the rich and worked for the prosperity of
his people, reducing the annual taxes by a quarter and revising the evaluation of property
for the assessment of fiscal charges.
Calm, peaceful and master of the passions that commonly be set the powerful, he had himself
depicted on the coinage standing, his eyes turned to heaven, thus affirming that the sovereign
must be a man of prayer and an intercessor for the peace and concord of his kingdom.
In his palace there was a room set aside to which he would every day withdraw into solitude
to pray and meditate on holy Scripture, and he often spent entire nights in the writing
of discourses in which he exhorted the people to the love of truth and virtue.
Having one day that someone had thrown a stone at one of his statues, he was asked to punish
the man responsible.
He smilingly passed his hand over his face and said, I don't feel any pain and I am in good
health and let the man go free.
Whoever approached him in the hope of being granted a boon was sure of being satisfied,
and one could truly believe, at these times, that God reigned among men.
Shortly after the thirtyth anniversary of his accession, which was celebrated with magnificent
feasts in 335, support the second king of Persia, unleashed a persecution against the Christians
in his kingdom, then breaking his alliance with Constantine, he invaded Armenia.
The devout emperor raised a mighty army to go to the defense of the Christians and decided
to take part in the campaign himself, but he fell ill in Eleonopolis and was hastily taken
to the outskirts of Nicomedia.
There he received holy baptism, which he had delayed for so many years out of reverence.
Refusing to close himself once more in the royal purple, he gave his soul into the hands of the
king of heaven and earth on the day of Pentecost in 337, still clad in the white tunic of the
Neophyte.
After having said a prayer of thanksgiving, his last words were, now I know that I am truly
blessed.
Now I know that I have been counted worthy of eternal life.
Now I know that I participate in divine light.
His body was immediately taken to Constantinople, where after a magnificent funeral in the presence
of all the people, it was placed in the church of the Holy Apostles in the midst of the empty
sarcophagi of the Lord's twelve disciples.
He who had been converted by a revelation similar to that of Saint Paul the Apostle to the
nations had now, through his colossal labors, brought the Roman Empire to submission to Christ's
doctrines and was thus glorified above all other emperors.
It is truly right that he has ever since been venerated as equal to the Apostles.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.